la unión europea' empieza a dar los
primeros pasos para crear una futura
misión de entrenamiento a las fuerzas
militares ucranianas así lo han apoyado
los suministros de defensa de la unión
europea para crear estos preparativos de
esta futura misión el objetivo es que
ucrania siga resistiendo a la invasión
de rusia en su territorio y sobre todo
para que se preparen para un conflicto
que se prevé muy largo para el jefe de
la diplomacia europea josep borrell es
necesario enviar no solo equipamiento
militar algo que la unión europea ya
está haciendo sino también es importante
poder entrenar a las fuerzas craneanas
de hecho no es la primera vez que se
estudia esta posibilidad ya se había
estudiado antes de la invasión de rusia
en cualquier caso tampoco es la primera
vez que las fuerzas o craneanas reciben
algún tipo de entrenamiento ya lo han
hecho algunos países europeos con el
envío de equipamiento militar y también
a la otan especialmente desde la
invasión de la península de crimea en
2014 y cuando empezó el conflicto en la
región del donbass en las próximas
semanas se empezarán a perfilarse todos
los detalles de esta futura misión a la
que tienen que dar a un luz verde
definitiva los países aún así el jefe de
la diplomacia europea considera que se
deben hacer todos los preparativos de
forma muy rápida